Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talked to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning, supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of
discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
It's been a while, but I'm
excited to start a new season
and series and I'm going to
start with a discussion on how I
think agents and foundation
models are are really a
disruptor to the current CAE and
EDA ecosystem.
This, this is of course is just
a personal opinion.
This does not represent my
current employer, NVIDIA, but I
wanted to share some, some
thoughts I've really had over
the past six months of how I see
this technology being, you know,
obviously a massive opportunity,
but also also a disruptor.
And so we'll, we'll walk through
that today from a technical
point of view, from a commercial
point of view, from a scientific
point of view.
And I'd certainly be interested
to see whether you agree with
my, my thinking on this.
If we take a step back and you
know, I'm going to look at as
often I do in this, in this
podcast through a sort of CFD
lens, but I think much of what
I'm saying is relevant across
CAE and and also EDA for chip
design, etcetera.
If you look, where did things
begin?
I would argue in the 60s and the
70s people were writing their
own codes.
Now, I've had episodes with
Professor Jameson and others who
who started writing codes
themselves before modern
supercomputing was around, and
those often started at academic
institutions.
Those codes then obviously
started to become useful and
there was collaborations with
industry, particularly in the
aerospace initially.
And that is why that then those
aerospace companies started to
work closely with those
developers and eventually
started to take them as their
own codes.
And that's why you see today
even there's a legacy of
aerospace companies having their
own codes written from scratch,
frankly, because there were no
other options.
And that was the way to do it.
The automotive sector then took
some things from the aerospace
sector.
And this depends on this a
little bit, whether we're
talking about structural
mechanics or fluid mechanics,
but it started off being you had
to write it yourself with some
expert developer.
Then over the course of, you
know, the 70s, eighties and
early 90s, those codes started
to become commercialized.
Those professors out of places
like Imperial or MIT or Stanford
started to, to, to create
companies.
And, and ultimately those are
the, the lineage, the lineage of
where Abacus comes from, where
Fluent comes from, where
Openfront comes from.
And in some ways those
commercialization was because it
was a natural thing as one
computing started to become and
make these tools more than just
a, a niche application.
HPC facilities, you know,
Beowulf cluster decided to
become commonplace and and of
course, industry started to see
the benefit of those simulation
approaches.
And frankly, then there was also
a competitive nature that once
one company starts, you start
having competitions between, you
know, the CD adapt Cos and the,
and what what is now the, the
Ansys and the later the
Dassaults.
There was that growing ecosystem
of companies that that compete
against each other, that
accelerates it.
The computing starts to get
better and other than those main
players, you also started to
have the hardware companies get
involved.
So the Intel's, the AMD, the
Dell, the Lenovo, the Cray in
those days, the the main people
building those those systems,
those supercomputing systems.
And if you look at how it
happened, that was probably true
for, for maybe 5 to 10 years or
so where it was mainly a
creating software to run on
workstations, servers and
supercomputers.
And that, you know, spread
across the world, frankly.
And those tools were very widely
used and started to create a
real, you know, hundreds of
millions or even billions by
then industry.
The the next technology that
really came around was then
around like cloud computing.
So cloud computing maybe 5-6,
seven years ago was, was a
disruptor because it allowed
and, and obviously I'm skipping
huge other things that happened,
but I don't want to spend 2
hours just giving the history
of, of CFD.
The reason I pick out cloud, and
I saw it first time working for
AWS, is it changed it from being
a purely software license point
of view to where these providers
could also have a control of the
hardware.
Packaging software and hardware
together is attractive for a
company for an ISV because they
can make profit off the hardware
and they can lock it together
both from a performance point of
view, but also from a sort of
stickiness point of view.
And there's advantages for the
customer in terms of making it
more seamless because often if
you just ship a binary, they
have to be the one to then
figuring out how to get the
hardware.
They are the ones who've got to
think about, do they need to buy
twice as much hardware?
If they want to run twice as
many simulations in the theory
of the ultimate SAS, then it is
fully scalable.
So if you're running, you know,
star CCM or fluent or power flow
or whatever, you could
essentially say, I want to run
10 times more and through the,
you know, infinite scale or
inferior of the cloud you can do
in the back end.
So that sassification was, was
something started maybe 6-7
years ago.
And, and obviously companies
like Rescale were one of the
first to do that at a cross
software level.
And there's others like Total,
CAE, etcetera who tried to, to
bring it together.
That is where I would say AWS
and Microsoft and Google started
to enter into more seriously the
CAE and EDA market as important
partners.
Because frankly, now it wasn't
just The Dells and Lenovos, but
you were deploying it on AWS or
GCP or or Azure or or Oracle,
for example.
Now GPUs obviously had been
around for quite a few years
before that, but but arguably
it's only been in the past sort
of three, maybe four years where
they have risen to become a
really important part of the
ecosystem.
And frankly, that's because a
lot of people have seen quite
clear benefits and they're
moving to the GPUs.
And that's another technology
point that's important because
it added a new competitive angle
to this because they needed to
able to run things on a GPU,
which meant that if you could
optimize your code for GPU can
get advantage.
This is where flex compute, this
is where luminary cloud started
to come out.
The rise of, you know, VC
funding for these sort of
companies led to a resurgence of
competitiveness, I would say, in
that market.
And I the reason I point to the
cloud before is that many of
those companies lent on as the
cloud being an additional sort
of angle to their to their
offering.
So at that point another thing
happens which is that the bigger
companies start to look to
consolidate and to start their
sort of acquisition period.
So you saw companies like
Siemens and the timing of these
are not all correct, but you
know Siemens and Altair, Ansys
and Synopsys, Cadence and Beta
CAE and point wise are future
facilities.
Many of these companies started
to acquire each other.
And why was that done?
Well actually so those companies
then wanted to start quiet and
of course this is where one of
the key technology came in that
starts to get to my point here,
which is the AI side.
It was, it has been around to be
fair, for maybe six years or
even 7 years.
But really it was since the sort
of ChatGPT moment in the early
twenty 20s, 2021-2022 that
brought this to life.
And so, you know, they started
some new startups to really get
hold and the newer concept, the
Physics X, the Navisto Extraity
MEAI, these companies started to
come about offering the
surrogate modelling capability,
the ability to do real time
simulations.
And that frankly was a threat
and an opportunity.
And I say that because that is
what I've heard when in
conversations.
It's a threat because anything
new is by definition a potential
threat.
These software companies who
have, you know, obviously had
quite a, a good position, see as
you know, how do we deal with
this?
But clearly it's also a massive
opportunity because it brings
new technology, new capabilities
to, to, to customers.
And that it has been a very
interesting thing to observe in
the past, let's say 3 or 4 years
of how do these larger companies
deal with it?
How do companies deal with it
who have their own codes?
How do they respond?
Do they respond with hype?
Do they respond with negativity,
with positivity?
And what happened was then some
companies decided to start
developing themselves, some
started to buy.
So Ansys bought Extrality, which
is now SIM AI.
Autodesk bought Navistone,
Siemens, you could argue and
some part of it was the Alta
acquisition.
And then some of these start off
start-ups that started with a
more GPU focus started to pivot
quite heavily to the surrogate
modelling.
So Lumia Cloud or Lumia AI now
and Flex compute, both of you
know pivoted to, to, to that
direction.
And so we, so we're at that
point now where the, the
ecosystem is at a very
influential point for a sort of
inflection point.
And there's one final bit that
is important to that.
And it's actually ultimately the
main topic that I want to speak
about today, which is agents.
Because the missing piece to
some of this has been if you
create a surrogate model and you
take it to its fullest extent
and you have some sort of
foundation model, you haven't
really got rid of the need to do
CAD.
You haven't got rid of the need
to do some sort of preprocessing
or post processing.
You could argue you've just got
a faster plug in replacement for
the for the bit of the solver or
the solve part, but you still
need all the bit around the
rest.
And that's why it's ultimately
been more of an integration play
through some of these AI
start-ups because you're not
going to replace CFD or FEA or
Eva, you're just really creating
an additional tool.
So in that sense you can
understand why the larger Isvs
and others have not necessarily
seen this surrogate modelling as
a massive threat initially
because they know that on it's
own it's it's not a replacement
that has led to of course 1
angle, which is if you were to
make a model that was so
generalizable, then it could
given the right plug and play,
disrupt some solver only
companies.
If you only produce a solver and
not the CAD and maybe not the
preprocessing, then arguably you
could, you know, replace some of
it.
But the technology that I think
it adds a real new dimension to
this is the agentic side.
Because what are what are
agents?
Well, first of all, let's tie it
back to the usefulness of Chachi
PT or Gemini.
We have all found them to be
incredibly useful in our
day-to-day tasks, but I have
personally noticed a a huge
shift in usefulness with the
agentic side.
And what do we mean by the
agentic side?
At least the way I define it.
Well, I think of it is just
simply now the LLM is able to
call some tools.
Now that's probably
oversimplifying it, but from a
practical point of view, instead
of me just being able to ask
some ask Gemini to do something
for me or, or codecs or
whatever.
Although the use of codecs now
is sort of murky in the waters a
little bit.
If I stick to like a chat
prompt, it's only going to be
able to really do things that
rely just on text or to A to a
limit where what I really want
it to do is to be able to go and
do things for me.
So for example, if I ask, I want
you to create a summary of all
my emails.
Great.
But what if I want you to now
look through all my emails, look
through all my Slack messages,
and then I want you to go in and
also look at a journal paper
that I'm writing.
And I want you to look at the
emails where I got some response
from somebody.
And I want you to take that, go
into, go into that.
Oh, and I also want you to go
and create some graphs for me.
So can you also create some
Python graphs using, you know,
map pot, Lib, etcetera.
And I want you to do that all
for me autonomously.
What I'm describing to you now
is absolutely achievable right
this second using cloud code or
codecs.
It is also possible for the
tools that that that that NLM is
essentially calling or the agent
is calling can be simulation
tools.
So if I extend that further and
I say I want you to be helping
me to do some journal paper,
maybe I could say now, well,
could you actually, could you
run some simulations for me?
I have an idea.
You know, here's some e-mail
correspondence, here is a thread
on a Slack channel with some
collaborators.
Not just write the paper, but
will you go and set up an open
phone simulation that that tries
out some of those ideas we
discussed and, and can you kick
it off?
And then when it's done, can you
create the graphs and can you do
it for me?
That's completely achievable
today.
That is not future thinking.
That is achievable today.
My point is in what part of that
then is this CFD tool?
The main thing it's not is it
because actually codecs or
clawed or vibe code now with
mistrial entering as a new sort
of player in this field from
with a heavy sort of sovereign
AI angle, European angle.
So codecs clawed or or vibe,
they can actually go and do that
for you.
And you don't have to be an
expert user of Open phone
because most likely those models
have either been trained on
sufficient smart data that
included Open Phone
documentation and various
reports across the web.
Or more likely that in a real
life scenario, and maybe this is
where the commercial bit comes
in, one of those providers could
have specifically added that
capability.
They could have looked at
science and engineering as a key
area they want to get into, and
so they will actually try to
make their models good at doing
this.
At that point, the stickiness or
the the difficulty of using ACFD
code is no longer there, which
is arguably one of the reasons
those codes exist or have such a
strong Moat because they're not
easy to use.
They require expertise, they're
very well validated.
If agent starts to come in and
very powerful LLMS come in that
can use these tools very well,
then actually the uplift of
changing to a different tool is
not as much.
And the ability to orchestrate
multiple tools is also the same.
So it raises a very interesting
question, which is are the
software companies just going to
reside to being just tools and
skills and actually your
relationship will be more with
the open AIS, the mistrials, the
anthropics, etcetera.
Or, and it is the case today,
will new companies arise that
are trying to do this?
Interestingly, and there's very
little public information on
this, but you have companies
like Prometheus, I think Jeff
Bezos put out some announcement
about wanting to create a
artificial engineer out of this.
So read into that what you will.
But it sounds pretty clear that
they want to build some sort of
capability like that.
You see the recent acquisition
of Meai by Mistral and you see a
huge interest from open AI and
Anthropic in general, AI for
science, which makes you look at
the future and start to think
there could be a new wave now of
companies coming around.
And there are companies that are
now base themselves purely to
create agents to create
artificial AI engineers.
This in some ways has the
opportunity to massively
democratize and and reduce the
need for you to be some
specialist.
An example I gave is I remember
when I was an engineer that
being a CAD expert was a
challenge.
You would have to learn how to
use NX or CTIA or SolidWorks,
and frankly, if you didn't know
how to use those, you couldn't
use it.
You would have to go and find
somebody, have to pay someone to
do it.
And I personally found it a
blocker actually, because I knew
what I wanted to do, I just
couldn't do it.
Now Fast forward and by the way,
similar extent to some software
tools where you know CFD, right?
I understand the theory, I
understand what I want to do.
I just don't know how to use the
code or I don't have to script
it or whatever.
As long as the Asian knows how
to do it.
I can say, you know, create this
in this scan package, set up the
simulation, this tool.
It's kind of interesting then
that it relies on a good skills
capability.
It relies on those tools being
open to agents.
And that is a very interesting
point, which is will companies
embrace this, you know, agent
first approach or will they try
to put more guard rails and and
even block people to use those
tools via agents?
Will there be some terms and
conditions and licenses?
And and that brings up another
point around licenses.
A lot of licenses are based
around a human having a seat on
a on a machine, and just like
cloud with the ability to scale
disrupted the per core license
model.
And really wanted it more to be
like a just a power session like
like Star has with his POD
license.
Finally, and I know this is
rambling on a little bit, but
I'm just dumping all my thoughts
down here, what about open code?
Open source codes?
Much of the challenge was around
support and capability and
validation.
Is it not the case now with
coding agents and the power of
LLMS that these codes actually
could become very capable and
and could be used more easily in
a workflow instead of a
commercial tool because the
agent can write and script and
validate and go off and do test
suites as much as possible?
So I'm not saying at all that
you will see a complete wipe out
of all the current CAE
companies.
In fact, it definitely won't be
like that, but I just put this
out that there is a very
interesting opening it because
these two new technologies
around sort of foundation
models.
This idea that you could have
simulations that would run in
seconds or minutes instead of
many hours.
The idea that if you have such
surrogate models and foundation
models tied with agents, you
could finally realize the sort
of reverse engineering or design
optimization, the automatic
generation of cases.
If you have a pipeline that is
able to do that, then you could
simply have agents go and
creating optimum geometries for
you, running those simulations
autonomously with you being
essentially the the
orchestrator.
The potential for productivity
is absolutely massive.
It is.
It could finally realize some of
the dreams of people in the CAE
and the EDA sector around
productivity boosts, around
finding designs around people
with just domain knowledge
driving the code rather than
code knowledge.
And that is important from an
education point of view.
I would say what matters more
now is not are you really good
at writing Python?
No.
Are you really good at using
Openfox?
No.
Do you understand physics?
Do you understand numerical?
But do you understand how to
pose the prompt?
Do that is more important?
Do you almost then it starts to
become that you need to go
higher up.
If it's so easy to run ACFD
code, why don't why don't I
start to run an FEA code as
well?
Many companies are you are split
if you are ACFD person or an FEA
person.
You're split if you're an
acoustics person.
Well, now you could become more
than engineer who simply is just
driving the tools.
That position in a company is
often the sort of chief
engineer.
Well, maybe now it's more
important that you understand
trade-offs and and larger
engineering concepts and doing
this sort of specialist deep
down analysis can be more
automated and clearly
simplifying what it.
There are many industries where
this will happen for many years,
but I'm I'm sort of trying to
Fast forward and play a what if
scenario to, to to all this
point.
It raises many interesting
questions.
Therefore, on the if the LLMS
and the agents are key.
It raises questions about
traceability around sovereignty.
Who owns these models?
Where these models done?
Should you be developing your
own models?
Can you take them off the off
the shelf?
So many, so many questions.
It, it rises, but I, I find it a
fascinating area that I think
will be a key technology driver,
an innovation area for, for, for
years to come and something that
I'd like to explore over the
course of this, of this season.
I want to look at speak to some
people who can give insights
into this on the the the core
ideas around sort of foundation
models.
Because the reason that
foundation models of surrogates
are so important is that if a
tool still takes a day to run
the the the agentic sort of
optimization workflows will
ultimately be massively Hanford
by the actual tool itself.
If the tool can match the speed
of the agent, the LM, then that
is what will really have the
breakthrough.
So whilst kind of the advantage
of the agent is that, and so as
you don't need to use any of
these surrogate model
technologies, they're even more
optimum when you when you do.
And, and so this is where the
the, the combination comes from.
So, yeah, I don't know what the
future will, will, will, will
be, but I know that it is
certainly an exciting one.
I think this is a great time to
be in the start up space.
It's a great time to be
researching, to be in academia,
thinking of your PhD, thinking
about what topics you want to
do.
It's a challenging time to be an
end engineering customer.
You don't know what to pick.
It's a challenging time to be an
established ISP, but it's also a
great opportunity because you
can potentially help drive your
company to bring out the next,
you know, industry 4 point O or
five point O or whatever the the
number is today.
So I will, I'll leave it there.
I'm sure I didn't cover many
things and I hope you appreciate
that this isn't me in any way
diminishing what will be the
classic example of any new
technology taking years and
years and years to them.
So I'm not saying next year or
even 5 years everyone will be
doing this, just like some
people are still running on
Windows 3.1 or Windows 95 in
some places around the world.
But I am confident, I am
definitely confident that if we
look in three years time that
the role of agents and, and and
surrogate models on AI will be
transformative.
And so please, if you're
listening, if you are one of
these people who are still
sceptic of AII would
respectfully encourage you to to
try it.
And I would hope that you will
believe me.
The final call out, and I will
say though, is in order to
convince the community, we need
transparency, we need openness
as much as possible within a
commercial mindset.
People who know me know that I
have always tried throughout my
career to, to do things in a
transparent and open way.
It's part of the reason for
doing this podcast is to sort of
share the knowledge.
The reason that I've created
these sort of open source data
sets is that desire to do it.
The reason for doing these
workshops or do CFD and others
is to try and share it.
I am fully appreciative of the
need for commercialization.
It's how the world works.
But I think the one key thing if
this agents and AI and
everything is going to be a
transformative.
People will only get on board if
they can believe it, if they can
see it, if they can see
transparency, they can see
publications.
I feel like academia and
scientific rigor has a massive
part to play in this
transformation.
And if it can be done with
scientific rigor at transparency
and good science, then I think
the the world will move on.
If it's done behind closed doors
with no publications, with just
sort of a, you know, black box
solution that that will not
convince.
And in fact, that will in some
ways be a barrier to this, what
I feel is transformative
technology helping.
So with that, I will leave it
there.
I look forward to hearing your
comments and I hope you'll join
me on this new season.
Please listen to the old
episodes.
There's quite a few, quite so
many hours, but I hope you'll
join for this season.
So with that, thanks for
listening.